in previous videos we've talked about
how various groups attempt to influence
public policy political parties interest
groups bureaucratic agencies even social
movements and we've talked about the
policy process model this is how a
problem is identified and potentially
addressed through a policy solution so
in this video let's bring these two
things together by thinking through when
and how each of these groups might
influence the policy process so let's
say that our problem is climate change
as we've discussed in other videos
climate change has only recently become
an issue that voters want to see
politicians address social movements
have put climate change on the policy
agenda with climate activists leading
marches and strikes to demand action
from politicians you will most often see
the influence of social movements at
this point in the policy process or at
the policy evaluation step take a moment
to think about why that is what are the
characteristics of broad-based social
movements that make it more difficult
for them to engage at other parts of the
policy process
well social movements are large often
led at the grassroots level and so they
might not have a central body that could
get into the weeds with crafting policy
when people go out to protest it's
usually because they want a policy to be
enacted to solve a problem or because
they're not happy with an existing
policy and they want it to be removed or
revised so that's why you might also see
social movements influencing policy at
the evaluation and change stage
okay so say that climate activists have
gotten their issue onto the agenda now
it's time for policy formation coming up
with a potential solution to the problem
which groups might be involved with that
this is a time when interest groups
might play a large role an environmental
group may have a strong opinion about
what goals the government should work
toward in curbing climate change whether
that's reducing carbon emissions or
incentivizing clean energy in fact an
interest group might even write
potential legislation for members of
congress in the policy legitimation
stage when the proposed solution is
debated and set to become law you may
see political parties exerting a great
deal of influence a party member in
congress may champion the legislation as
a representation of their party's goals
or work against it because it conflicts
with their party's goals this stage is
also when the federal budget process
takes place so you might find
bureaucratic agencies or departments
campaigning to spend more or less money
on the policy
now the law is on the books let's say
it's a law to reduce carbon emissions by
25 over 10 years and the money is lined
up to fund it it's time for the
implementation stage so which groups
might attempt to exert influence in this
stage of the process
well definitely bureaucratic agencies at
least one of which will be tasked with
implementing the new law this is also a
time when interest groups will be really
prominent remember the law might have an
overarching goal reducing carbon
emissions by 25
but it's up to the bureaucracy to come
up with the specific rules that will
make that happen so interest groups
representing coal
oil or solar power might attempt to
influence those rules in their favor now
the last stage of the process evaluation
who do you think will want to have a say
in how effective the policy has been in
solving the problem if you guessed
everyone you're getting the hang of this
policy-making thing experts in the
bureaucracy may undertake a formal
analysis of data to understand how well
policy goals have been met political
parties may want to tout how effective a
program they sponsored was or critique
how ineffective a program they opposed
was interest groups may request
adjustments to the program to better
serve their members and social movements
as we've already mentioned might turn
out to protest or on rare occasions to
celebrate the outcome of a policy and
then the whole process starts again